how much money do you have one year $20  about you 10 I'm trying to live my dream  by preparing for three auditions back of  the line I haven't even gotten ready job  yet I've been taking on a bunch of  freelance chefs  hey squirrel trying to buy some lemonade  I just need the money or different $10  that'll be $20 I get a fee because I  have no money yep so you're charging  people for being poor next this boy's  really care about you don't they yeah  they do  you're my friends and I love you I just  don't know if I'm doing the right thing  out here I'm just gonna keep working  hard keep believing just accept me for  who I am and we don't make it I truly  believe it I could see me now look easy  mean the mirror across a sheet what up  Playboy